Willie, in this section of the video,
apparently provides fake studies, okay?
Willie
Willie Mac Show, apparently
provides
fake studies in order to win a debate or
win a YouTube battle, YouTube conflict
with DarkViper. All right, I'm going to
set a goal really quick. I'm realizing
Paul, he's made a 100-page
paper
debunking Willie Mac's studies
and calling into question the
credentials of Gliscor. And there's like
actual, you know, trying to figure out
the credibility of the graphs. Give me
two Give me two paragraphs and maybe
maybe a little closing statement. Okay.
Let's say Keemstar made a video essay on
on on Ethan, right? On H3H3. And his
video essays generally Let's say they
I know it was a bit of a meme, but
DarkViper recently So, he's made a lot
of videos on Willie, right?
So, we have um Where is it? Where is it?
Where is it? We have part one,
part two, part three, part Four videos
in total, amassing to about 8 hours, 9
hours of run time. Now, these are a big
meme pretty much, cuz who the [__] is
watching
nine hours of YouTube content about
Willie Mac, right? Who's watching that?
I don't know. I I'm, you know, I'm not.
But I might. I might. The issue is
Willie Why on earth did this Willie, in
this section of the video, apparently
provides fake studies, okay? Willie
Willie Mac Show, apparently
provides
fake studies in order to win a debate or
win a YouTube battle, YouTube conflict
with DarkViper. All right, I'm going to
set a goal really quick. I'm realizing
Oh, please give me money. Okay, I need
money. I need I need money, fellas. All
right.
Feel free to donate. Listen, we've been
going for about 2 hours. Feel free to
donate. It's all appreciated, okay?
We're going to watch this one section
from Willy Mac. All right, we're going
to watch this one section
where Willy Mac alleges something
against Willy Mac or or DarkViper
alleges something against Willy Mac,
okay?
And what he alleges, I think, is pretty
serious. And I want I want your guys'
opinion on this, okay?
>> to debunk him a second time. So, if I'm
seeing his second video on the whole
doesn't matter, why did it still delay
this video? In the video, Willy claims
to have hired a data analyst to look
into reaction content for his video.
Since my last DarkViper video, I linked
up with a data analyst named Gliscor. In
reality, he was merely using the work of
someone from the drama community, and it
was Gliscor who reached out to Willy.
Not for his second video, but his first
video, the one I'm responding to. To
describe him charitably, Gliscor is a
professional idiot with delusions of
grandeur. More importantly for us, he
has open
>> So, a lot of this stuff about Gliscor,
I'm going to I'm going to give some
commentary here, obviously, okay? I
don't want I don't want Willy Mac to
kill me, per se. All right, I don't want
him to kill me, per se, okay? I'm sorry.
Um but this Gliscor guy is a [__]
[__] from what I've been able to tell.
Uh he doesn't really go into it a lot in
this video, but Willy Mac uh one of
Willy Mac's buddies one of Willy Mac's,
you know, little cronies made a or or
DarkViper, I should say, sorry. One of
DarkViper's cronies made a 100-page
paper. Okay? Mm.
[__] I'm tired. Sorry. One of Willy
Mac's little little little goobers made
a 100-page
paper
debunking Willy Mac's studies
and calling into question the
credentials of Gliscor. And there's like
actual, you know, trying to figure out
the credibility of the graphs, uh
calling into the the sanity of Glissette
because Glissette is a [__] insane
person if you actually look into any of
this.
Um
Some of the comments are pretty funny.
Take this as you will, obviously, but
let's just watch this section cuz this
section basically TLDRs the uh the
paper.
>> openly antagonistically hated me for
years. He has spent an incredible amount
of time online arguing about my views of
reaction content despite very clearly
not understanding them. So confusing is
his lack of understanding at this point
that we've openly discussed how that
>> Death Stranding 2 was cocked. What do
you mean?
What do you mean?
>> can be possible. To be clear, when I say
his
>> Hideo Kojima sucks. He ruined it. What?
Huh? Are you [__] What? Huh.
>> lack of understanding is baffling, I
mean that literally. Me and my team have
openly discussed how it is possible at
this point that he still does not
understand. Long ago, he in fact got
very offended when I communicated this
to him directly. Despite knowing of all
of this, you can probably see why Willy
lied to avoid including any of this
information.
>> No post-game content, predictable story.
Uh the first game didn't really have
post-game content, either.
Uh and I would I would argue that the
first game's story is pretty
predictable, as well. I don't know if
you're playing Death Stranding for the
the story that's told to you to your
face, though. You're definitely playing
it for You either like the mechanics of
the game, you find it interesting to
play, or you probably uh you probably
like
uh you know, the undertones that the
story serves rather than the you know,
the upfront stuff, right? I like I I
mean, I haven't played it. I haven't
played the second game. I don't have a
PS5. I wish I did, but I don't,
unfortunately. But, so I don't know if I
can really speak on it too much. I am I
have high hopes. I really do like the
Death Stranding first game. It was very
epic, very good. So, I don't know.
>> As it makes anything Glissette says,
very questionable. Originally, when we
watched Willy's second video, we just
found Glissette's inclusion very funny.
The data that Willy brings up in his
video does not relate at all to the
>> If chat gives you money, you can give
you we can you can get a PS5. Yeah, give
me $700 for a PS5 and Death Stranding,
too.
>> issues that I bring up with reaction
content. It cannot even potentially
address any of the arguments I make
about the topic. And even people who
dislike me felt motivated to leave
comments pointing this out. Again, it is
that age-old question of whether Willy
is still knowingly lying about my views
or if he is just too stupid to
understand me. More embarrassingly, he
doesn't even seem to understand what
arguments are or how to substantiate
them. You can likely therefore see why
all of this initially was very funny to
us. Unfortunately, this humor turned to
concern when someone on my team named
Spider observed that all the data
Gliscor gave Willy was fake. Understand,
not merely irrelevant and unable to show
anything of substance, actually fake. To
what degree this was intentional
>> See, so he alleges that the the studies
are are essentially entirely fake.
Okay.
>> or inadvertent, what
>> Ask Lynn unless you harass Lynn about
race play. I did not I DM'd them. I I
told them that I'm not racist. Actually,
hold on. Where where are my DMs with
Lynn? I said, "Lynn, I'm not racist."
They replied, "Hmm, you're not like an
evil racist. You're one of the good ones
that will let us have rights, but have
preconceived thoughts about if we're
going to mug or rape you."
I replied, "I don't think you'd rape me
if that counts for anything." They
replied, "One day at a time." Uh so, I
I don't Are they threatening to rape me?
I don't I don't fully know. I don't
understand exactly what that means what
that response means.
Um
So, I'm not really sure what plans Lynn
has, but
>> wasn't immediately obvious. Both Gliscor
and Willy, directly and by omission, lie
constantly, but they also do not
understand the topic. Although, given
that Gliscor hangs around with and
supports grifters like Willy, that's
probably another reason you shouldn't
believe what he says as well.
Regardless, it seemed like something
that should be looked into and it was
this that delayed this video. While
letting Willy continue to lie about me
personally was one thing, his spreading
a fake dossier about a topic that
actually has implications for other
people was another matter entirely. So,
we decided to wait until Spider had the
time to do a formal write-up explaining
why Glitches data was flawed. Spider has
physics and math degrees, so it's in his
wheelhouse. Just as an aside, I'm
>> So, again, TLDR, right? TLDR Viper's
going to strike. Like you don't care.
Don't care. Don't care. I'm just
watching this section.
Um cuz I feel like this is just more
It's better than reading that entire
[__] paper. Um
TLDR, what what he has just said, right,
is um
Glitches, who has no formal credentials,
no credentials at all, and has provided
allegedly, according to DarkViper, fake
fake graphs, fake data to substantiate a
point against DarkViper. Um
has been debunked by someone with uh
master's degrees, someone with actual
statistical, like, you know, analysis uh
background or whatever. Like, someone
who can literally I don't know what the
professional term would be. I'm not I
don't [__] know. I'm a [__] okay?
I'm a I'm a [__] I'm I I'm not going
to front it with you, all right? Um but
they were debunked by someone who
actually does have official, uh you
know, credentials and stuff like that.
Like, actual degrees and the stuff that
would be required uh to substantiate,
you know, a graph like that.
Right?
That is essentially what's going on
right now. Willy Mac has grabbed a
random Glubshitto, okay? Random
Glubshitto
uh out of nowhere, and then used them to
substantiate an argument against Willy
Mac, but it turns out that Glubshitto
provided allegedly, according to
DarkViper,
fake data, fake graph data to
substantiate that point, okay?
That is what's going on.
>> But, we have at least one other person
who really
>> Did DarkViper prove the credentials of
his dude. Um, I believe so.
This is a 100-page paper. I haven't read
it all yet. Let's see. Maybe not. If he
does, it's not in the table of contents,
it seems. Which would be a little
hypocritical if you're claiming, you
know, complaining that this guy doesn't
have credentials and then your guy
doesn't prove his credentials, right?
That is a point against uh Dark Viper
there.
If he does prove it, it's not in the uh
table of contents, which it probably
should be. I don't know. I haven't read
the entire report yet, so I can't I
can't say for certain.
>> realized the problems with Glissette's
data. I don't know him personally, but
apparently he has a background in civil
engineering and he's currently studying
data analytics and data science. I'm not
sure how, but apparently
>> I don't know. Did a chat GPT?
Hey, sure.
Sure. Sure. Can you summarize the Let's
see. What do we got here?
>> Here's a concise summary of the
Glissette WMS report based on the
abstract and the first 13 pages you
provided.
Summary of the Glissette WMS report.
Purpose of the report.
This is a statistical and ethical
critique of work presented by Glissette,
who contributed data analysis to a video
by Willy Mac Show in the ongoing debate
over whether reaction content harms
original creators.
The report claims Glissette's work is
deeply flawed both in methodology and
motivation.
Main criticisms of Glissette's work.
One, statistical failings. Misuse of
normalization methods. Inappropriate or
incorrect data types. Flawed or
misleading graphs. Small sample sizes
that invalidate conclusions. Logical
disconnect between results and
conclusions. Use of statistical tools,
e.g., Shapiro-Wilk test without correct
application.
Two, questionable credibility. Glissette
is repeatedly called a data analyst by
Willy Mac Show, but there's no clear
proof of their qualifications.
The report casts doubt on whether
Glissette holds a relevant degree in
statistics. Glissette's vague references
to being in STEM are seen as
insufficient to justify the authority
being granted.
Mhm. Three, personal bias and conflicts
of interest. Glissette has shown
appreciation for react content since at
least 2019.
Publicly disagreed with DarkViperAU, a
known critic of react content in the
past.
>> Okay, I'll just give it the the PDF.
I'll just give it the PDF and and give
me like
summarize in two paragraphs. Give me two
Give me two paragraphs and maybe maybe a
little closing statement. Okay.
Take a look at that. Take a look at
this, ChatGPT. All right. ADHD. Do you
want to sit here and listen to ChatGPT
go through this entire [__] report?
Yes, her voice was lovely. All right,
the conclusion is Glissette's analysis
is not only methodologically invalid,
but also ethically compromised. Both
Glissette and analysis,
whether due to incompetence, bias, or
deliberate deception. Glissette is unfit
to be a neutral or credible
analyst in a debate around reaction
content. Wow. W, is Glissette's
data analysis
outright
fake? Based on the Glissette report,
that claim isn't that Glissette
fabricated data, meaning he didn't
invent fake numbers, but rather that the
analysis is so poorly constructed,
biased, and methodologically broken that
it leads to false or misleading
conclusions. Is it functionally
worthless or misleading? Yes, according
to the report, the report argues that
Glissette's analysis is invalid
statistical built on invalid statistical
methods based on absurdly small and
cherry-picked samples from literally one
unretracted video, contains obvious
graphical and logical errors, including
a visible math mistake. What?
What? Math mistake? Okay, cool. Flips
the experimental logic and normalizes in
the way it distorts relative view
performance. Okay.
Um can you review the PDF I sent you
unbiased
and verify and source
to see if Glisset's
uh
data is indeed flawed. Let's see this.
Let's get unbiased ChatGPT and on the
case and I'll get the woman to read it.
>> Yes, an unbiased review of the PDF
reveals that Glisset's analysis is
indeed flawed, but not outright
fraudulent.
Key verified points from the report.
One, not fabricated, but
methodologically flawed. There's no
evidence Glisset faked or invented data.
His numbers appear to be based on real
YouTube analytics. However, the
analytical framework and conclusions are
statistically invalid for several
reasons.
Two, statistical errors and oversights.
Here are the most significant flaws
verified directly from the report.
Preposterously small sample size.
Glisset used only one unreacted video as
a control for an entire channel,
Internet Anarchist, which is nowhere
near enough for any meaningful
statistical inference.
Misuse of normalization. Normalizing
each video's view rate by its own
maximum distorts comparisons. It masks
real differences in between reacted and
unreacted content.
Reverse use of control test groups.
Glisset aggregated all reaction affected
videos into a control distribution, the
exact opposite of what standard
scientific testing requires. As a
result, his method erases any signal of
harm or benefit from reactions.
Graphical and calculation errors. A
featured graph had mathematically
impossible uncertainty bounds. The error
bars, standard deviations, were
asymmetrical, which is invalid under
Gaussian distribution assumptions.
Another error
>> You guys get the You guys get the gist.
Essentially, super small the [__] that
Willy was trying to pull
is is literally just like
Can you ask them to give you an answer
in layman's terms? Um answer
in
layman's uh terms in one paragraph.
>> Willy Mac's data analysis isn't fake in
the sense of made up numbers, but it's
seriously flawed to the point where its
conclusions can't be trusted. He only
used one non-reacted video as a
comparison point, which is nowhere near
enough to draw any real conclusions. And
he processed the data in a way that hid
any actual effects reactions might have.
Some of the graphs had math errors that
would be obvious to anyone with a stats
background.
And he also flipped how control and test
groups should be used, which completely
invalidates the analysis. So, while the
data might be real, the way it was
handled was so poorly done or biased
that it gives a misleading and useless
result.
>> True. Okay, so Willy Mac is basically
just like a wretched fraud.
Um he does not have a strong point
against Dark Viper.
Dark Viper, whether you guys would like
to admit it or not ultimately, he is
right. And I believe, if I'm remembering
correctly, uh Chud Logic even agreed at
one point saying, "Yeah, Dark Viper
ultimately uh is right. Legally, I'm in
the wrong. Reaction content is not fair
use. Reaction content is
uh illegal to do. If someone reacts to
my video, I can [__] take them down.
It's not fair use. No no reaction
content is fair use, right?" Which is
you know, part of the reason why
uh I'm so against the Ethan lawsuit
because he's not going after everyone
who's unfairly react reacting to his
content. Uh he is going after people who
dislike him.
Right? So.
So, so, so, so, so.
What does this mean? Willy Mac.
Uh, did Willy Mac lie? I don't know. It
is just a extraordinarily bad argument
to use someone who does not have a
background in stats, uh, who makes some
math errors in their graphs,
uh, you know.
Obviously [__] ridiculous. I'm not
sure if there's anything else to really
point at here.
I guess.
Um, could we watch this section and I
can show you guys how far down is it?
It's this one.
>> Recently we've been at
>> Yeah, data analysis. So, see what he
says here.
>> videos. But as we all know, correlation
doesn't necessarily mean causation. And
that's my problem with this
>> Is it an error if it's intentional? It's
an error in that his math is wrong.
So, yes, even if it is an intentional
error, it's still an error. Yeah.
>> whole dialogue. It's all based on vibes
and people's personal opinions. So, I
wanted to change that. Since my last
DarkViper video, I linked up with a data
analyst named Glissette. We then have
>> So, see, he uses B-roll. He does not
show or cite anybody like any
credentials or anything like that, which
again, to be clear, this is not like a
legal issue. Anybody can be a data
analyst, right? Anybody can. If I say I
am a data analyst, I am a data analyst.
That's how that works. It's not like
being a doctor or being an engineer
where there are like it is a protected
whatever.
Anybody can be a So, it's it's it's it's
not like super egregious. Anybody can be
one, right? The issue is using those
credentials when you don't know what
you're talking about.
Uh, to then substantiate an argument
against someone you're like beefing
with, uh, to like win an argument
essentially, right?
>> had the Act Man and Internet Anarchist
send us videos that both were and
weren't reacted to. Glissette then took
each data set and modeled each day as a
normal distribution. The final result
for Internet Anarchist is this. So, you
see the black line there? That's the
sort of the average view count
uh of a reacted video.
>> Which again, for these studies, they
only used one unreacted video.
Right?
And this is from someone who already
gets millions and millions and millions
of views being Internet Anarchist,
right? So, this does not represent what
this data would look like for a small
channel that only gets maybe a couple
thousand views, or a small channel who
has a shared audience, uh you know, with
with whoever. It's like um
What's a good example of this? Let's say
Queen Man made a video essay on on on
Ethan, right? On h3h3. And his video
essays generally, let's say they usually
get around 2,000 views, and he has a
large shared audience with Chud, right?
And then, Chud, the same day the video
is released, decides to react to that
video. And Chud, you know, maybe Chud
has 2,000 viewers at this time. All of
those 2,000 viewers may not, uh you
know, be natural viewers that the would
have watched the video naturally, but
regardless, that is a large amount of
the audience that would have already
watched the video, who now has no reason
to watch the video. That being said,
they could still go rewatch it. The
video could get pushed in the algorithm
super hard, but that initial boost is
taken away, right? So, what this data
shows, it does not show the average
YouTube experience for react content.
Right? Now, obviously, I'm pro react
content. I'm reacting to the content
right now. I think it should be allowed,
right? But, I recognize that not every
single reaction is going to be fair use.
And there's not like a strong legal
precedent set for something like this.
So, I would not want something like this
uh pursued in court. I would want
reaction content uh culture, if you
could even call it that, to to, you
know, prevail on YouTube and whatever.
But, uh this data is just in like
flawed, insanely flawed, like [__]
This literally means nothing. This is
like extraordinarily meaningless.
Literally means nothing because they're
using one video from a guy who gets in
millions of views. They're not using
videos from smaller channels who would
actually be affected by react content,
right?
>> Uh sort of
it it's dimensionless view count which
effectively means that I've divided it
by the maximum view count
which basically just makes each video
more comparable to each other.
Otherwise, you'd have
all different lines going all about the
place.
>> The shaded areas are the standard
deviations. If the line is in the dark
gray area, that is one standard
deviation. The light gray is two. A line
being within either means there isn't a
statistical enough difference in views
to say that react content is affecting
the work. But if it leaves the shaded
areas, that means it's statistically
significant. A trend is being formed.
>> For for Internet Anarchist, there's
I think most significantly
or I suppose uniquely about Internet
Anarchist to the situation is that there
are regions where that pink line
leaves the shaded area. I call that
uh very loosely statistically
significant.
>> When it leaves the shaded area, does
that mean the video is getting doing
better or is it doing worse? What's the
story?
>> if it was if it was above the line, then
it would be doing significantly better.
But because it's below the line, the
unreacted video is doing significantly
worse
than a reacted video.
>> When it comes to the Act Man, we get
different results.
>> see in Act Man's case sort of from this
one here. It's a much sort of steeper
curve than in the case of Internet
Anarchist which makes this sort of
analysis a little bit more difficult
because noise is a little bit more
>> You guys get the point.
Do we watch this entire thing? Probably
not, right?
Probably not. Yeah, you get the point.
Willie's like [__] He doesn't know
like he is he is he is I'm not going to
say he's lying. I feel like lying is
very um
a very strong way to put what he's doing
here. Um but Willie Mack is being
extremely dishonest. I feel like calling
him dishonest is a very fair way to call
this behavior. He's being very dishonest
here in his portrayal. Right? I think.
Being very dishonest, being very
epically dishonest, okay? Being very
epically dishonest. Um
how long have I been live? 2 hours. 2
freaking hours. Wow, W.
Um hm, I don't know. Do we keep going?
I I wanted to talk about the Doc's [__]
the Doc's drama with Willie Mack, but I
don't know.
I don't know.
Um
he like made a [__] tweet and then
deleted it. I could go over it. I don't
know if I will. I think 2 hours is a
good time, a good time. All right, 2
hours is epic. 2 hours is epic. I might
end it here. A good time. True.